in 1910 airplanes were a novelty Jew in this
crowd had ever seen one before the meet was
sponsored by the Aero Club of California one
of the first organizations of its kind here
are the judges good substantial businessmen
who kept both feet on the ground there were
no fools and those days pilots had to have
plenty of nerve and a whole lot of push
he got a quick start and it looks like he's
heading for a quick finish here is the famous
inventor Glenn Curtis demonstrating one of his
first plain crude but it blazed the trail for
the giant airships of today the finish of the
distance flight that set a new record 45 miles
in one hour 2 minutes 42 and 450 seconds and
the winning pilot Paul Hann of France the man
shaking hands with Paula Hannah's Bronco
Billy Anderson the first movie cowboy and
this is the kind of reception of flying hero
got in the days when Lindbergh was a small boy